so I'll entitling this Mormons and think
about what the mainstream actually means
and what it used to be and what it means
today you know a good launching point
for this would be thinking in terms of
the Broadway show the Book of Mormon
which is a huge hit how did that get
started those of you who are in the know
what about that anyone remember who
wrote it or South Park people exactly
and so what do you think I you know they
they did an episode about latter-day
saints and again that they were you know
as the self part people do there's sort
of equal opportunity when it comes to
religious they make fun of everybody's
beliefs everybody's abortion everybody's
structure organization everybody's
culture actually one thing I do like
about them is they don't they don't play
any fades and they saw that they're sort
of talking about the same stuff in this
book they're doing in this in a
satirical comedic way but they're
talking about these tensions that
Mormons faced with an American culture
and the perception of other Americans of
them and their religion and when you say
tension we've talked about this a lot
before with other groups there is the
broader American culture and that might
be dominated by one group or another
we'll talk about which groups were
dominating your mother and then you know
every religious group has distinctive
beliefs distinctive practices that's
what makes them what they are that's
what we call their their identity so if
you think about yourself you have a
personal identity as you know so and so
I'm not going to say any names that were
recording this front part of their going
to be constituted by gender or that can
be constituted by your background part
of that could be kind
to what part of the nation you actually
grew up in if you listen to my voice you
realize I'm not from here because I
speak with a sort of Midwestern
wisconsin accent when I said Wisconsin
that comes out that's part of my
identity now the the tension is this we
saw this a little bit before with
Catholics we're going to see it with
Judaism how much you adapt yourself to
this because if you want to fit in you
want to get by it sure helps to look and
sound and think and behave like
everybody else but if you want to hold
on to your identity that's not really
going to be a full option for this
there's a tension here you have to make
decisions and so religious groups do
this sort of thing let's think about
this end of it now the American
mainstream we're talking about is this
chapter begins like the 1870s 1880s
who's the American mainstream who is the
dominant establishment religiously
speaking in America at that time it's
not the Catholics right yeah Alison yeah
and then what would Protestants if we
have a big general term for it when
we've used a lot this semester
Protestants is right is it the
Lutheran's Oh cousin aliens yeah
portunity now we're starting to like get
into that that that a broader
designation because the Presbyterians
have less ritual less liturgy look this
term evangelical right when we talked
about the sort of establishment they're
the ones who are more or less dominating
American culture at that time and so
they're the ones that the Mormon
are looking to as sort of you know both
rivals through the dominant culture so
if you want to be a subculture you have
to be kind of opposed to but also
they're adapting to them to a certain
extent or evangelical Protestants the
sort of majority American culture force
at this time not really they've become
sort of a subculture haven't they and
there really isn't something that we can
call the one single group that
predominates but we could say something
like secular society what we mean by
secular society a society in which
religion plays less and less and less
enroll in which is sort of relegated to
the margins son so Norman's have been
you know existing in tension with the
mainstream secular society can hamper
they're just people in it but religious
people are sort of expected to keep
their mouths shut in your heads down
keep their beliefs or practices to
themselves will turn on Sunday or
Saturday or whatever alright make
religion to be something sort of quaint
and not really an issue so it's changed
over time who their their counter poison
themselves against it's a matter of fact
one of the things your book talks about
as time is going on as secularism became
much stronger latter-day saints found
that they actually had a lot in common
with evangelical Protestants they
actually had a lot in common with the
sort of you know we might call it Norman
Rockwell America
apple pie baseball not sort of gay
stereotype they had a lot more in common
with that than they do is with the
contemporary secular society they are
rather conservative in many respects so
this is all stuff to sort of keep in
mind your book talks about some changes
that take place in the 1890s this
President Wilford multi-goal what a
president means to that in a moment he
has a manifesto and it brings to and the
distinctive practice what's the first
thing that you think about somebody says
Mormon still today probably leg of me
yeah now most Mormons are not
polygamists there was a time where you
that wouldn't be true but at least with
the the main church the Church of Jesus
Christ of latter-day saints that's you
know centered out in Utah which
represents the majority of Mormons on
that ended in 1890 that actually set led
to some splits because some people said
now we're going to keep the polygamy
there outside of the main Mormon Church
they are what the book refers to a
Mormon fundamentalists not the best term
for them but you might you might say you
know sort of original asst or radical
Mormons or whatever whatever a
designation you want for that there were
a lot of other changes that took place
at the time your book brings up physical
separation doctrinal peculiarity
economic semi communitarianism or what
does that mean that's a long word semi
communitarian what would
communitarianism and then we'll worry
about the semi that's not a term that
they defined it okay it was a
communitarian you guys familiar with
this term no well yeah
this isn't say individual community yeah
the individuals are sort of you have
your meaning as an individual within the
community so you know if you think about
the sort of practices of the engagement
in Utah Lake is a massive land
reclamation as a desert that takes a lot
of people not thinking about themselves
and thinking about the larger project
the common use you know submerging
themselves in kind of group identity
that's that's what they're talking about
there then all sort of went away your
book talks about the ending polygamy but
I'm actually I'm not going to talk very
much about that let's look at some of
these other shifts that took place
playing it's you know like your books as
Mormons are now among the most vocal
advocates of individualistic capitalism
in the nation that's a big shift away
from a communal identity isn't because
individualistic capitalism means I've
got a nice stuff you've got your stuff
keep your hands off of my stuff and if
we want to cooperate we'll write a
contract and you can pay me or I can pay
you but it's not about some big common
good it's about you know whatever the
market can can tolerate whenever you can
get through your goods and services in
the market so Morgan isn't like your
book points out adapted to its
incorporation in American society not by
abandoning its earlier practices and
values but by creating a network of
beliefs values and structures and all
this stuff over here capable of
maintaining their identity as a
distinctive people in the face of the
pressures of religious competition
competition mainly with with Protestants
and I'm resisting secularization
secularization in religious terms means
religious people quit being religious
they become secular so you know here's a
prime example of this many many college
students find when they go off to
college they may have been attending
services regularly with their family
when they were in high school because I
was expected in the family then they get
to college and what what happens
what'swhat's you're not necessarily your
experience but you seen this happen with
a lot of people they keep going some do
but what most do yeah they sleep in on
Sunday right it is it's nice to have
brunch you know there's all sorts of
things that come up like that that's
becoming more and more secular and so
somebody might still identify well i i'm
still a baptist i'm still a catholic but
if you're not actually practicing it the
sense in which you're a this or that
becomes kind of you know anemic becomes
kind of water down and so they're trying
to avoid that sort of stuff that the
laminations we're trying to avoid
secularism your book talks about them
having a distinct set of beliefs or
theology a distinct way of worship we'll
talk about that in a moment a structure
of organization and similar and yet
different from other religious
organizations and all these are so
tightly connected that they constitute a
culture or what we might call subculture
with an american society there's a
distinctively latter-day saints and warm
and way of living out the decide entity
so let's start with belief your book
talks about and this is just review for
you the unique revelation with Joseph
Smith it was claimed to have derived it
through his encounters with this angel
Moroni the authenticity of the Book of
Mormon and Joseph Smith's prophetic
rolls or cardinal points of faith this
came up in that south park episode
didn't all right how many of you see the
south park mormon episode only a few of
them how many of you like soft park ok
so later on today you know go go and
look it up it's very funny you may find
it offensive perhaps but you know like
it says south park equal opportunity
they go after everybody even even though
the non-religious people too but you
notice that one of the key things that
comes up in there is what about this
golden tablet stuff what about this this
book of mormon stuff and they say we
have to take this as a matter of faith
these are what we would call articles of
faith these are these are things that if
you compromise that you're not going to
have an awful lot left after it happens
what else let's look at some of these
other key things about their belief
system talks about a lack of sense of
transcendence transcendence means where
you've got you know something that's
much higher than something else and
there's a radical break between it so
for example in tradition traditional
Christian theology human beings and the
angels are distinct kinds of beings you
know I remember when my mom died made
all [ __ ] lots and lots of people came to
the funeral I was in the receiving last
about six hours she was so popular and
she was the head of them she was the
secretary for a massive club and a lot
of these people would come through and
you know you guys have all been to few
miles you shake people's hands you say
I'm sorry for your loss and you might
say up a little bit so a lot of these
people would say things like well she's
an angel in heaven looking down on us
now that shows a sort of lack of
transcendence traditional Christian
theology human beings don't become
angels their radically distinct types of
being and the angels at least the ones
that didn't fall are somehow you know
transcendent to the human world that
were within the world of our ordinary
experience so when you say there's a
lack of transcendence it doesn't mean
that there's no God doesn't mean there's
no divine beings it means that there's a
continuity between the human what is it
we experience like you know you're
looking at me hearing things and the
supernatural or the divine so they kind
of interpenetrate each other your book
talks about their view they're what we
call their anthropology
view of human nature human beings are
not really that different from God in
this point of view they're uncreated and
eternal they're capable of change and
development both in this world of the
world to come one other really telling
difference they don't believe in
original sin in their view there are
sins but there's no radically flawed
human nature from from the start so
humanity like it says thus enjoys
extraordinary freedom to fashion itself
into something quite literally divine
our Mormons the only people who believe
in this no because there's a
long-standing traditional Christian
notion of sales of becoming guy but it's
always been kind of at the fringes they
talk about life in this world is not the
beginning or the end of human existence
human beings enjoy to pre-existence
before they left voluntarily and then
they grow further and then depending on
how they behave that the determined area
in the afterlife so these are all going
to fall under the theology the beliefs
structure or organization this is this
is something very important to you can't
have a religious institution continuing
very long without somebody actually you
know doing the day-to-day things of
organizing of making sure that the
lights come on in the church you know of
actually doing sunday school you know in
the case of latter-day saints they talk
about first the distinction between
genders so this is a very you know
traditional conservative faith in that
it sees men and writing as kind of
complementary roles not as doing the
same thing patriarchal imagery from the
Hebrew Scriptures was informing Joseph
Smith's vision and so what do we see
here traditional gender roles for women
which would mean one being lawyers
high-powered executives or traditional
gender roles whether you like them or
don't save all moms yeah and so you see
a lot of it the idea is that the man is
supposed to be earning you know
providing for the family and the
household is where the woman is supposed
to be attending to everything making
sure that that doesn't fall apart that's
a lot of work actually and you know
you'll find this out when you have to
manage a household a lot of thinking
involved in managing a household your
book talks about priesthoods as well and
joseph smith through these revelations
he said that you know what was in what
was happening was a restoration of the
the ancient Hebrew priests it's the
ironic and Melchizedek Priesthood how
that actually plays out in practice is
as a young man or really a youth is
growing he's progressing through some
stages on roles and your book talks
about being a deacon Deacon means of
servants not a servant like a slave but
a certainty ask somebody who actually
serves other people it's the original
Greek term the teacher and priests and
then there're recognized as adults
through initiation to the status of
elder now you might say well that's kind
of weird to be an elder when you're only
19 years old but remember this is this
is a you know this is coming out of the
front here where all of us would
actually I would be a pretty old person
you'd already be established in whatever
profession is that you're doing you've
been doing it for quite a while they as
elders they spend two years supported by
themselves as missionaries either in the
United States or abroad they go all over
the place and ran into a kid who is
about to leave on his mission work going
to Britain of all places at a conference
dancin that's all sort of individual
human being strong
right then what about organization they
have the award and the state and the
word you can think of it's sort of like
a parish it's about the same size as a
lot of parishes in traditional Christian
churches and they'll have you know a
sacrament the sacramental meeting that's
taking place with the ward chapel that's
the religious service that they're
attending weekly first Sunday of each
month they've it fast and testimonies
some day where the worshippers are
abstaining from food that fasting for 24
hours and then they offer personal
testimonies what are they doing in their
services talks him singing
administration of the sacrament of
communion notice it's not why that's not
even grape juice it's bread and water
that's all happening up of worth level
that's where families are if are coming
together that is at stake is composed of
a number of wards so you can think of
that as something like a diocese or like
a synod depends on what organization
they hear you're in at this level they
have templates there's always new
temples like your book points out in the
process of being built there's a main
temple in Salt Lake City but as
latter-day saints have spread out
throughout the United States spilling
out of Utah if you actually look at you
know remember that map that I showed you
at the beginning of the semester where
you can see that large parts of Arizona
Nevada Idaho there's through the
dominant group within that net area they
hate you know to have a central place to
go to we'll talk about why temples are
particularly important in a moment so at
the higher levels they have these states
these are administrative units that
usually have about 8 to 12 awards they
have a president but the president is
actually three people president with two
councillors presidency and then they'll
have a High Council of twelve seventeen
it's what they call your book calls it
jaron toc recei never heard of this word
this is a good more to learn because
this is a complete aside but your lives
as young Americans are very much
determined by old people you know what
your economic prospects are what's going
to be available to you what the nation
looks like is really not in the hands of
my generation it's in the hands of the
generation before means baby boomers and
they be done a lot of good things a lot
of bad things and they have determine
the kind of expectations that you can
have they're also living a hell of a lot
longer and not getting out of the way
for any of the younger generations to
move up they're going to run the show
for a long time that's what you call a
gerontology literally rule by the agent
in this case it's more individuated but
that's what that term actually means
when you come across that in there
before now your book talks about a few
other things having to do with with
structure in terms of shrines in terms
of the main temple the main temple it
affects about in terms that access mom
do you remember that idea from really
early on shrines for places that were
important so we're talking about you
know in in Missouri Illinois New York
Joseph Smith's story you know all of
that let's talk now about worship though
how are they distinctive in worship
we mentioned a little bit about what was
doing if reward level there is a number
of other things that are happening and
they're happening at at the temple level
and the word Bishop decides who gets to
go on to the temple and that's where
these these ordinances which are held to
be very important for the latter-day
saints are actually occurring so what
would be examples of these we've talked
about baptism for the dead before just
quick review the idea was people who
died from your family your ancestors who
didn't have the opportunity to run into
this new revelation of a Mormon they
kind of got screwed didn't they they
know this is this a classic problem that
that missionary religions have had what
about people who didn't get to hear the
message are they in a you know in a one
down well by being baptized as a proxy
for your ancestors you would be offering
them that possibility of salvation so
that's part of why the Latter day Saints
have been so interested in genealogy
they are a major resource for everybody
researchers use their server stuff
endowment ceremonies and sealing
ceremonies are two others that you book
talks about and these are really unique
to latter-day saints endowment
ceremonies are these rites of initiation
undergone by young adults before setting
off on missionary work or marriage and
it involves a ritual bathing and
anointing with with oil then this
happens in the temple not you know in
the ward ceiling ceremonies bind a man
and woman together for time and eternity
so you know as opposed to think about
what what marriage vow is usually
comprised right how many of you planning
to get married sometime I don't raise my
hands on knowledge
so weird if I was planning to do it
again what are the models include what
do you want your spouse to be saying to
do it they're committed to you yeah
they're not going to sleep with anybody
else right the negatives was like get
attached anything eyes right so that's
important what else yeah through through
sickness and health rich and poor you
don't want to abandon you when you go
bankrupt either right so what else oh
well actually let's follow up on them
because that's going where I want to go
through rip through those how does it go
rich or poor sickness or health how long
forever and ever till death do us part
so that's saying okay I'm going to be a
little facetious here so I love my wife
you know but if she gets sick and dies
well we had a good run now it's okay for
me to find somebody else that kind of
goes against some of our notions like
you know when you marry somebody they're
supposed to be thought one right give
these romantic notions for these ceiling
ceremonies they're literally saying
we're going to be together through
eternity no death do us part in the
afterlife we're going to be together so
that's that's really distinctive they're
going to be very committed to do that
sort of thing it also talks about some
other things occurring with with worship
body of full songs many dealing with the
hardships and ders during the trip to
Utah persistence does a distinctive
Mormon hymnody they have their own
musical traditions there's also an
entire folklore surrounding these sort
of providential deliverances legends
about Smith and and Brigham Young and
then a book mentions the story the three
Nephites and these are these three
strangers who mysteriously appear to
have to help Mormons in distress
they vanish story is still making and
sort of anonymous rounds your book also
talks about their their culture this
work health education recreation complex
that's that's something that's stressed
within not just the teachings of the
road trip but within the entire
community so you see everybody else
doing this sort of stuff and then that
makes it a lot easier to do now you put
talks about the political and sort of
social conservative ISM of latter-day
saints some examples of this until
nineteen seventy eight black males are
barred from the priesthoods and then the
president you know said well we have to
change that I've got a revelation and
done that that's pretty recent right
that's the generation and a half from
from from now Mormon attitudes towards
the role of women remain very
conservative these traditional gender
roles so recently your book also talks
about there was there was a policy known
as correlation this is a policy of sort
of controlling the development of church
teachings and activities keeping them
within the hands of the centralized
church so that you know they do this
through a lot of pamphlets and
directives and that kind of produces
local bought on local expressions your
book talks about their involvement in
politics which which way do you think
these guys are evolved Republican or
Democrat yeah or in Conservative Party
you know tends to draw that they're
actually the religious group there's two
there's two groups demographically that
are most easy to print and when it comes
to the presidential elections what is
the African Americans for Democrats the
other is latter-day saints for
Republicans at this time that may change
but at this time those are the easy
predictive I Mitt Romney was who you
know rammed in recent election he was he
is a latter-day sink he actually had to
give some speeches explaining how you
know was this compatible with say being
the president and taking care of all of
America he actually gave some very
interesting speeches about the role of
faith in public life not so much in the
last election but in the one before that
when when McCain was the candidate those
are well worth reading the last thing is
what talks about is some some some other
groups that are latter-day saints and it
really only talks about three groups one
is more or less died out that's the the
straying i'ts the ones who follow Joseph
Strang they have dwindled hey there
pretty much negligible and the other two
groups would be kind of at opposite ends
of the spectrum one of them is what used
to be called the reorganized Church of
Jesus Christ of latter-day saints which
is kind of a mouthful is it a lot easier
now they're called the community of
christ they change their name to
emphasize that there are a lot more like
evangelical Protestants in many ways
they're actually mainline Protestants
because theologically they're quite
liberal they ordain women they don't
make any sort of racial differentiation
they're open to ecumenical relations
with other Christian groups they're
pretty small as a group they don't have
the numbers that the main latter-day
saints church has but they are still out
there and they're they're still there
still a presence they have their temple
in in Missouri and their temple is
actually you can visit it's open that's
probably enough about them the other
groups would have a think about are the
ones that even down to this day if give
people the impression that the first
thing we think about it I think about
Mormons is polygamy right those would be
what we call the fundamentalist Mormons
they will be even further to the right
that the latter-day saints there are the
ones that are out usually in the deserts
places where it's harder to to get to
them although like your book points out
there are a few you know in the salt
lake city area they just keep a very low
presence because polygamy is illegal you
know I was that was something that they
had to deal with early on some of them
said no we're going to continue this so
I'm sure all of you have seen some of
the TV shows you know sister wives
that's what that those are not about
main Church latter-day saints those are
about those splinter groups so that's
pretty much up for latter-day saints for
our class I suppose one thing I want to
do since we are ready this stuff up is
ask there are there any questions or you
guys can about addressing so we haven't
actually looked at any things that we're
like in the back your mind or should we
go on for the topics all right good go
on with a new journey